so you've got a story about two best
friends that kept a promise from years
ago
yes these two guys in wisconsin are
proving you cannot put a price on
friendship
tom cook and joseph sp afini split a 22
million dollar
powerball jackpot here they are with
their wives in the obligatory oversized
novelty check and a cow
wearing a dress for some reason this all
stems from a pack that the pair made
three decades ago in 1992 they vowed to
split the prize if either one of them
was to ever strike it rich playing the
lotto and it happened
tom bought the winning ticket and
immediately called joseph who at first
thought it was a joke anthony
the odds of winning the powerball
jackpot are about 1 in 292 million i
wonder what the odds are that we have a
friendship
like tom and joseph was a great friends
a real prize
finney who's an average fisherman when
his friend called said are you jerking
my
bobber i love that i love it no sir he
was not enjoy your 11 million dollars
thank you vlad